Kevin Farley's coming in just a little
backed up yes welcome hi how are you
Kevin this is Christian you met in Libya
yes you guys are old elevator bombers oh
we're a little backed up with guests we
had a guest come in we weren't planning
on so it kind of pushed our buddy back a
little I'm glad to be here man yeah well
welcome sit down yeah we're all fans of
your music yeah yeah they're together
equals us you plus me was together to
get the number two that was back in 2000
something like that I was in a band
called together boy band we were MTV
show that spoofed boy bands and I was
the older brother type I had braces on
and stuff you were an adult that I was
that very 36 year old man in a boy band
you know at the time and it was a blast
though God we it was weaselly Steel
Panther where I was supposed to be a
goofin instead of beginning it was
ballsy of MTV because MTV was making all
their money off boy bands yeah and then
they come out with this thing which is
completely goofing on boy bands yeah
right exactly right exactly so we were
surprised that they did it
then we had a sitcom that gave us two
years on a sitcom and we actually got to
tour with Britney Spears and for a
little while
did you well what happened was basically
we we pulled up to like the Verizon
Center in LA and we were like there was
stages in the parking lot mm-hmm and we
were like who's gonna be on those stages
and they're like well that's you guys
basically hay bales but it's just so
funny because the band it was just
supposed to be like a made-for-tv movie
where she's a goof yeah but then it
became so popular that they actually had
you guys go out and perform yeah did you
get to meet Britney or they just keep
you outside thank you yeah I'm working
with Britney Spears and you're gonna
[ __ ] Bella hang up yeah that's what
happens if you were in a boyband you
could have a shot with her that's true
that would have been a real boyband yeah
and sure she was with at that time
Justin Timberlake
yeah at those days that JT now is that
is that official that's right yeah
that's right MySpace JT
[Laughter]
Marley yeah the one with the down the
river it was shot up in Connecticut a
couple years ago I forget what it was
very vengeance oh yeah yeah
are you the I know which one you mean I
hope we're both in that film are you
shoot together you guys you guys are
such Hollywood remember the names
Apocalypse Now
are you still Jesus let me Chicago he's
still in LA no I just moved to New York
now oh you are I was in LA for you know
20 years and then I thought I tired of
this and I'm doing more stand-up now so
and the stand-up is better here and the
East Coast so I moved to New York and
moved on that yeah it's great
what'd you do before that before you
doing stand-up in hockey will you like a
second city got to or no second city you
are second city improv Olympic that kind
of thing yeah I never did you see B but
I did second city improv Olympic when I
was I born in Madison I moved to Chicago
in the mid 90s and then did all that
improv there you know like Second City
and improv Olympic all those guys you
know so when Chris becomes you know what
Chris became on SNL uh-huh are you going
like what the [ __ ] now I can't do SNL
because like you created this amazing
shadow it never would have gone on as I
couldn't have he was such an icon on
that show then I wouldn't I would be the
dumbest thing I could ever do to go
right now but if you're in second city
if it's not for him that's a goal right
no I had never really thought of seconds
our SNL just cuz I knew once he got on
that show I was like it's over oh he's
gonna destroy that he's going to destroy
you know I knew it right away and of
course I'm like well he'll take that
whole [ __ ] thing and I'll just go to
like it sitcoms or something like that
or do some regular acting but I wasn't
going to touch that as we all know
younger I'm the one you're younger
oh yeah yeah okay was there any jealousy
or no no how do you be jealous of that I
mean you can't really be jealous he was
he was a freak of nature will he be
surprised when I've been jealous I've
been jealous oh my god yeah it's gonna
be jealous of great things and awful
things
are there people that just bring the
noise never be even when we were little
I could never be as funny as he was he
was just what was that like I mean
funniest guy no what's that like growing
up with Chris Farley I mean well no I
mean he was insane it was more insane
than he was like on camera no oh god
yeah oh yeah
wait wait crazier and what point are you
like wow man like you're such a funny
guy and you're you're getting high all
the time what point did you notice like
this is a problem oh when he was younger
yeah when he was younger in high school
when he first took it you know drink
wasn't good you know some people just
have an allergic thing you know and that
runs in the IRA where our I don't know
what it is the Irish no we should not no
we shouldn't yeah we knew it right away
I mean the first time you ever had a
drink it's bad oh you can kind of tell
something in the minute you know some
people just have a bad reaction I get
exponentially funnier when I drink I
should have drank before some people are
there light-hearted and fun and other
people are just crashing down shitty
yeah that's a probably extreme
personality types where it's like if
we're gonna do something we're gonna do
it to level 100 that Chris was the
funniest guy with a couple of beers and
the worst guy with like seven so there's
that line where you're like what though
was he angry you know you never an angry
guy just like you're like oh god what
happened you know yeah it's like you
know all of a sudden the light switches
with a lot of addicts and that kind of
thing yeah something happens you like
where this is not how you started out
exactly and she's not gonna go back that
night
arrested or passing out it's always bad
were you happy with the with the way the
documentary came out and did the
documentary yeah only because I wanted
to straighten the story out so many
stuff has been so much stuff has been
said about him that I wanted to switch
it to like you know he was he was when a
partier he had a problem an addiction
problem but I wanted to you know people
that worked with him loved him you know
yeah so I want to just put out a
different version of every that was
retiring I mean everybody wanted to help
him yeah everybody liked him everybody
loved him everybody thought he was a
great great but a lot of things that are
said after you die you know and I'm like
this isn't fair cuz he's not around
right you know so I wanted to try to
store his unfair that people said he was
a while out of control he was pretty
quiet it's kind of a shy guy you know
and and yeah I just thought that people
thought he was just out of control all
the time he had a lot of time years of
sobriety years of hard work and years of
sobriety wasn't just a full you know
minute to wait right sure minute you
wake up when you go to bed just doing
blow and all that it wasn't like do you
do you think he had to he think he had
to do that to be that guy in order to I
don't think he did all that hurt that if
he liked and Tommy Boy he was totally
great working on all cylinders and that
was his best thing so now he didn't he
know that stuff just hurt him that stuff
just really brought him down instead of
brand mob he was much better without it
do you party at all or no do you know
the opportunities to of course and then
I Mike well obviously my blood isn't
good it might be something in the family
yeah no god no no I mean the like I said
I don't know if it is the Irish thing I
don't know what it is but yeah I got a
couple uncles we got a couple you know
that we guys we can't do it you're just
not built for it not built for drinking
right
the Irish I'm not made to casually drink
no right no no no you're better off just
leaving it alone
yeah when did you when did you start to
get serious about stand-up maybe five
years ago hi welcome to The Comedy Store
and just started doing like Sundays and
Mondays and you know that kind of thing
and yeah I just started doing it you
know and I liked it it's a challenge and
certainly not fun to bomb ah but I've
learned a lot you know it's not like
improv improv you when you bomb you got
other people with you sure so you're
like god you sucked out yeah the you
can't blame it on anybody when you're in
Staunton have you bombed a lot I bombed
sure sure I mean haven't we all maybe no
yeah of course of course I did stand-up
for three years oh yeah I mean let me
let me amend that I tried stand-up for
three years
yeah no one was giving me a microphone
so I decided to take one myself and
following Jesse Jackson was kind of like
that time at Rascals in Ocean County New
Jersey where I went to do an open mic on
a Wednesday night and the headliner just
decided to show up to sharpen up his
routine sure and Bobby Gonzales I'll
never forget it he was the the MC just
goes and I said hey the headliner for us
was West Orange who was it
Jackson something I don't remember is
Jesse no not if Jesse Jackson chippy
Jackson yeah Jackson no but I I
performed in front of two people at a
dive bar and no one even looking at your
you know doing a five minute routine
even five minutes that stuff you'll come
in for half hour it's tough to bomb in
front of two people it's nothing you
should be able to win over there not
even bombing when they're not paying
attention to you right even actually
worse than a bigger crowd yeah and right
but it doesn't even feel good when you
do well in front of two people exactly
even if they both brought two friends
you're left with like what really is the
word Dangerfield to do that sometimes
you'd have to do the show I've done
Dangerfield that's a rough one I used to
be such a great great
back in the day going in danger village
it was a hot club obviously Ronnie's
alive and all that but man it was good
yeah I looked there a lot over the years
and what happens where they stopped like
no matter what people did in the
audience they would they wouldn't like
back to comics so I'm kind of like I
just stopped for that reason like I like
the guys who work there I like the staff
the art but when they wouldn't tell
people to shut the [ __ ] up we're gonna
knock just like we might put myself to
that for right exactly we don't please
the crowd or anything like that yeah
exactly yeah yeah look hecklers I've
gotten better at just because sometimes
I like a good heckler you know once in a
while like I hope they say heckle me
then I can kind of go off my act and
maybe lose my [ __ ] a little bit it's
fine nothing wrong with that yeah which
is I don't mind but then when it gets
out of hand then it's off I let my good
guys the best heckler handle ever was
was a Jake LaMotta De Niro in Raging
Bull make a comeback [ __ ] you
don't bother me I'm trying to do my
routine the comedian wants to say we
don't want to be witty we're gonna
bother me I'm trying to do my routine I
love it when they snap like that I have
seen a few stand-ups lose it on stage
and snap Michael right yeah you just
have the inner fun he just came across
like a fun guy yeah exact same thing
aegeon and white people it's what
Seinfeld said it was an episode it was
entire episode of the show where do you
want me to go to your place of
employment and heckle you and I think he
did in that episode yeah he went down to
her line of work and he started heckling
her scene comedians lose their [ __ ]
though it like it reminds you why
stand-up is special it reminds you that
it's this live thing that's happening
right now and only right now and at some
point somebody could completely lose
their [ __ ]
I think stand-up has invited the heckler
in and yeah because there's a whole
thing about crowd work when you're doing
like improv the audience is pretty much
they're part of the show so they're kind
of nervous about saying something dumb
or you know suggesting something dumb so
they're pretty behaved
but then stand-up has invited this whole
drunken coursers drinking and then I
don't know and then the crowd work and
that kind of thing so which is humanize
are gonna end humanizing to the idea of
a guy in a microphone it's like well I
can talk I'm a guy yeah vitae microphone
so if you think you're funny you can sit
there in the audience to me like we
won't funnier than you yeah and start
firing stuff Adam whereas if you're
seeing a band or something you're like I
don't know how to play a guitar
no I don't hear you you know right
exactly once in a while that you yell at
the banjo and the band will stop playing
because they're doing something annoying
but most people just scream it abandoned
no one hears you right nobody hears
which they have a guitar which I wish I
had a guitar so do i I wish I could play
the guitar on stage and I would just
drowned out everything like that one guy
breaking over someone's head that famous
video I love it he's justifying it like
we should she said that you know he said
it was uncalled for
did you ever lose it did you ever lose
an eye well yeah I mean but I try to be
funny while I'm losing it if I just lose
it like snap like then it's not good but
I've tried to be funny so you have to
lose it and contain yeah which I'm
pretty good at anyway you know but yes
I'm angry
but I try to be funny I try to work in a
few jokes so that they go is he joking
or is he gonna hurt us right so and they
don't know how close you are to actually
hurt yes yeah I handle it like Tom Hanks
and punchline that was the best way to
comedian